[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So first of
all, welcome to the Big Android
BBQ.
This is my first
Big Android BBQ.
How about you guys?
Have you been before?
Or are you guys all
first timers today?
AUDIENCE: First timers.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
How is it so far?
Key note sounds like
it was fun, right?
I'm looking forward
to the food later too.
My name is Laurence Moroney.
I work for Google as
a Developer Advocate.
I specialize in a technology
called Google Play services.
And my role is generally
speaking, writing,
working with developers around
using Google Play services,
and some of the related
technologies around Google Play
services in your application.
And one of the
related technologies
is Google Cloud Messaging.
And today I just wanted to
talk a bit about messaging,
talk about the type
of things that you can
do with Google Cloud Messaging.
And most of the
session, I'm actually
going to be building a
very simple Google Cloud
Messaging based app on
stage with you guys.
And it's actually going to have
a live server where messages
can be sent to my phone.
And the URL will be exposed.
And people tell me it's
a mistake to do that,
but I assume you're
all going to behave.
So without further ado, Google
Cloud Messaging is what I said.
And I always, whenever
I talk about messaging,
I always like to begin with a
story of what messaging used
to be like.
About 10 years ago, I was
working in Wall Street
as an enterprise architect.
And there was one
project that was
given to my company to deliver
for a major international bank.
And this project
was that they wanted
to have instant
messaging, chat style
messaging, for all
of there terminals,
they had 30,000 terminals.
And they wanted instant,
direct messaging.
Every terminal receives every
message within a certain time
frame.
And on average,
each terminal would
issue about 100 messages a day.
So can anybody do the math
say for 30,000 terminals
around the globe?
How many messages would that be?
It's a lot, right?
So if you think about it, you
have 30,000 terminals each
issuing 100 messages, and
each receiving 100 messages
from each of 29,999
other terminals.
You're talking
about, what was it?
It was like 9 by
10 to the 9 number
of messages floating around
in this system every day.
That's a lot of messages.
That's a lot of scale.
Now, of course,
when we brought it
to the customers who were
saying that they wanted
to build a system this
way, we're saying,
you can't just
flood your network
with messages like that.
You've got to design your
system in particular ways.
You keep closely related
messages close to each other.
So take, for example,
this customer
had branches in Singapore,
in London, and in New York.
And we were saying,
well, you know,
99% of the messages in
Singapore, the people in London
don't care about them.
And 99% of the messages in
London, the people in Singapore
don't care about them.
So we started
carefully designing
the network for these messages
so that you wouldn't completely
flood your network with
messages in order of 10
to the 9 every single day.
And so we ended up-- we spent
about six months designing what
this thing would look like.
And then we brought it
back to the company.
And we brought it
to their ops people.
And their ops people
took one look at it
and said, nope, not
going to happen.
You know, because even with
all the design work that
was put into this, the
amount of infrastructure that
would be necessary to be
able to handle something
like this was just obscenely
expensive for them to build.
It was way ahead of its time.
It was pre-Cloud.
And it just-- the
project got canned and it
ended up being replaced by a
bulletin board system, which
effectively gave them the same
functionality where anybody
could go and take a
look at a bulletin
board of the messages that
had been posted by anybody
else-- sorry-- anybody else,
anywhere else in the world.
And as a result, they
got the same kind
of functionality but
without that instantaneous
communication.
Now when I look at something
like Google Cloud Messaging,
I'm not going to tell
you that you can quickly
and easily and cheaply scale to
10 to the 9 messages every day,
but you don't have
to think about all
this backend infrastructure.
And that's what Google Cloud
Messaging, to me, is all about.
I like to look at
it as a black box.
And in that black box,
I can send messages.
And that black box
routes messages
to all of the clients that are
registered for my application.
It does it for free.
It does it instantly.
And it does it with lots of
other types of functionality.
I can go Upstream messages,
Downstream messages,
Peer to Peer messages,
all that kind of stuff.
And did I say it was free?
It is, actually, free.
And because it's
Cloud technology,
it scales really nicely.
So what we're going
to do today, is
we're going to take a
little bit of a look at what
an application built on
Google Cloud Messaging
looks like in action,
how it will perform,
the type of
performance that you're
getting for free, the
type of scale ability
that you're getting for free.
And we'll take a
look at what does
it look like to build a simple
application in Android that
uses this, and then
an App server that
also uses this built
in PHP and MySQL
and hosted on a free web host.
So as I mentioned, what
is Google Cloud Messaging?
First of all, it's
a hosted service,
Google hosted service on our
infrastructure, on your behalf.
It manages the queueing and
delivery of your messages.
Your messages can be
Upstream to servers,
and may be stored in servers
like a bulletin board style
system that I mentioned.
They can be Downstream, which
is much more interesting, where
your users can receive instant
notifications of messages
in the system.
Or they can be Peer to Peer.
So my people in Singapore,
my people in New York,
in my earlier example,
could communicate
with each other over something
like Google Cloud Messaging.
You can target single
devices with messages
or you can target groups
of devices with messages.
And what I'm going to build
a little bit later on,
you'll see where I
have two devices.
Number one is the
emulator on my machine.
And number two is
this phone beside me.
And I'll show how I can target
messages to either of those
or to both of those
at the same time.
It supports topics.
So again, thinking
of my bank example,
I could have a set of topics
that are relevant for Singapore
and a set of topics that
are relevant for London
and people can subscribe to
what they're interested in.
And the infrastructure, this
black box infrastructure,
will handle the rest.
And it's relatively
easy to build.
First of all, that backend
infrastructure nightmare
is taken out of your hands.
And while there's a few hoops
that you have to jump through
in order to, for example,
get things like an API key,
we're working on making
it easier and easier
all the time to do that.
All right so what
does it look like?
So this is what a
basic system would
look like as we're building it.
So the first thing is--
remember I've been talking
about GCM as a black box.
So this GCM black
box on the right
is something that your
apps will register with.
And when they register with
Google Cloud Messaging,
using an API key
that you set up,
you'll get a token
back that identifies
your app in the Google Cloud
Messaging infrastructure.
So that black box on the
left, is provided by Google,
you build nothing.
You call APIs on that.
You get your registration
tokens back from it.
Step two, then, in a
server based system
like I'm talking about is
you build your own App Server
that then stores these
registration tokens
in order to identify the
people who are using your App,
and in order to be able to
send messages to the people who
are using your App.
And that's what I'm
going to be building
in PHP in just a moment.
So your Apps will then
pass registration details
that they have achieved from
GCM to your server, where
your server can store them.
And you can store
them with whatever
identifiers you feel are
appropriate for your customers,
for your clients, within
an enterprise that
may be different than if
you're working with the public.
And then step three-- if
my slide will cooperate.
There we go.
So then step three is your
App Server, in this case,
will tell Google Cloud Messaging
what to send and to whom.
It calls APIs in that black box.
And it says, send this
message to the person who's
identified by this token,
or send this message
to everybody identified by this
token, or send this message
to this topic.
And then people who subscribe
to that topic will receive it.
And then Google Cloud Messaging
will deliver those messages
on your behalf for you.
All righty.
So how do you build it?
The first part of doing this is
going to the Google Developers
console and getting an
API Key and a Sender ID.
So your API Key is
what identifies you.
It's a unique thing for you as
a developer on the Google Cloud
Console that will allow us
to understand who's using it,
how they're using it.
There are no throttles.
There are no rates or anything
like that on the system.
So it's not going
to be used to say,
you can only have
this many messages.
But it just allows
us to prevent people
from being naughty
by maybe having
trying to do a denial of service
using Google Cloud Messaging
or something along those lines.
And then the Sender
ID is something that's
unique to your application.
So maybe you have
multiple applications
that you're building, and
that Sender ID would like--
in my banking scenario, you
might have one message that's
used by the buy side--
sorry, one application that's
used by the buy side
and another one that's
used by the south side and
you have different Sender ID's
for these, just so that
you can separate them.
There's two ways for doing this.
You can go to
Google Cloud Console
and step through
everything yourself.
Or there's this new thing
that's only just come out
in the last few days.
And it's the URL
at the bottom here.
It's a quick start,
developers.googl
e.com/mobile/add.
And there's a
wizard on there that
will register your
application, get your API Key,
get your Sender Key,
turn on the APIs for you
to use and all that good stuff.
Then step two is to build the
Android Application itself.
So how do you build the
Android Application?
Well first of all, you need
to use Google Play Services.
Actually, who's familiar
with Google Play Services?
OK.
Most of you.
Cool.
So Google Play Services,
it's a set of APIs
that we ship that get updated
roughly every six weeks.
And it allows you to
access a lot of Google
back services,
things like location,
maps, fit, et cetera, et cetera.
And Google Cloud Messaging APIs
are shipped as part of that.
Now you need to set up some
permissions in your Android
Application to allow Google
Cloud Messaging to work.
Typical things that
you need to turn on,
like internet access,
that type of stuff.
In your manifest, you're
going to do two things.
You going to add a receiver.
And you're going
to add a service.
If this isn't
clear, don't worry,
I have code in a moment that
shows that I'm-- I don't know
if you are like me, I tend
to think in code rather than
in slide where, but I just
want to list the things here.
So you're going to
need a receiver,
and you going to need a
service in your manifest.
And then finally, you're
going to need a class.
In order to receive
messages in your app,
you're going to
need a class that
extends the GcmListenerService.
So earlier on, I had that
black box sending messages
down to your application.
If your application
extends GcmListenerService,
and your application is
registered with Google Cloud
Messaging, then that's the
part of your application
that will receive those messages
and know what to do with them.
So what does this
code look like?
OK.
First of all, including Google
Play Services in Europe,
is as simple as adding
something to your gradle file.
Can anybody spot the
mistake in this slide?
Or spot something that's
outdated in this slide?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm
using the +, rather than
a particular version number,
which is naughty, you're right.
But there's one other.
AUDIENCE: 8, 1.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 8.1.
Thank you.
I've actually put
7.8 in this slide
for a very specific reason.
And that is, if you try
doing 8,1 with the emulator
right now, it doesn't
actually work.
So I downgraded my code to
use Google Play Services 7,8,
just so that I could use
it in the emulator here.
So well spotted, both of you.
Now secondly, it's just
defining the permissions
that you need in your
application in order
to, for example,
access the internet.
The wake clock, allows
a message coming in
to be received by
your application
so that it can generate
a notification.
And then this last
one is, again,
it's the received
permission for Google--
so for I almost said
Google Play services--
it's the received permission
for Google Cloud Messaging.
Next up, you're going to find
a receiver in your application.
And it's pretty straightforward
XML in your application,
like this.
By the way, if anybody wants
the source code for this app,
I'm happy to share it.
My contact details will be at
the end of the presentation,
instead of trying to scribble
down code off a slide.
And then, finally, you need
the service, of course,
for your applications.
This service, you're
just going to define it.
My application was
called com.google.daver
ell.lmoroney.gcmtalk.
And I put a class in there
called my GCM listener.
And I just had to set that up as
a service with an intent filter
specifying that it's
going to be received.
And here's what the listener
class would look like.
So once we've set up all
the metadata that we need,
this is what a
listener class would
look like, something that
would receive messages
on your behalf.
It's pretty straightforward.
It extends the
GcmListenerService.
And it overrides on
message received.
And on message received,
you get two things.
Number one, you get a string
with the from, and that's
the person that's sending
you an-- idea of what's
sending you the message.
It's usually the server.
And then you get a
bundle with the data.
And the bundle with
the data is going
to be a JSON message with a
lot of details about the data.
But the actual message
that I'm sending
through my server,
the text message,
gets prefixed with an m.
That's why I have
here string message
equals data dot get string m.
And then out of
that I'm just going
to generate a notification.
You can do whatever you
like, of course, when you
receive an incoming message.
You can render it in
one of your activities.
But for this demo,
I'm just generating
a notification in
the notification tray
with the actual message.
OK.
So let's take a look
at what this would
look like in Android Studio.
OK.
Well that's what the
application looks
like with my beautiful design.
I'm not known for
my design skills.
OK.
So first of all, I
mentioned, build.gradle.
So here if I go into my
build.gradle on my app.
You can just see I've defined--
I'm using com.google.andro
id.gmsplayservices.
I started this
application just by doing
an Android Studio a file
new MT activity application.
And I've added a
few things to it.
Instead of going
through all those steps
and boring you
here, I'm just going
to show you the completed one.
So here was where I've
added Play Services 7.8.
In my Android Manifest--
is this font too big
or can the people
at the back read it?
Because I know there's not a lot
of code visible on the screen.
I just made it nice and big.
So again, in my
Android Manifest,
I've set up the permissions
that I want to use.
So there's the user's
permission and you
can see the three entries here.
Then, there's the
receiver that I want.
And it's going to be a com
Google Android GMS GCM GCM
receiver.
And then, under my activity,
you will see the service.
And that's it.
So the three things
that I had set up,
the permissions, the
receiver, and the service,
are all that added to
your Android Manifest.
Now in my main activity--
let me show you
what my main activity
would look like.
It's pretty boring.
So I just wanted to
create a very simple one.
A couple of text boxes.
One where you enter your name,
one where you enter your email.
Sorry, it's hard to see on here.
And then a button that you use
to register this application
with Google Cloud Messaging.
So if I go to my main activity,
and in my main activity
you'll see there's a
text box for a name,
or an edit text
field for a name,
there's an Edit text
field for the email,
and then there's a button.
On that button what
I'm going to do
is register the application
with Google Cloud Messaging.
And that's done in here,
where I'm just setting up.
I'm doing as a
background task, which
is where you see the
asynchronous stuff there.
And on Google Cloud
Messaging, this number
here was the Sender ID, that
I spoke about earlier on.
So I get my API Key, which
is associated with my Google
account.
And I get a Sender ID, which is
associated with my application.
So this is the sender ID for
this specific application.
And I just get that
back as a reg ID.
And then the rest of it,
that's the only thing
that I'm doing to register
with Google Cloud Messaging.
And then the rest of this is now
posting to my backend server.
You can see here on
the client I just
went to one of these free
web hosting companies that
will give you PHP and MySQL.
And they gave me this
URL, gcmtalk.side40.net.
I put a PHP file on
there, which I'll
be showing in a few moments.
And I'm just posting the name
that the user has entered,
the email that the
user has entered,
and the registration ID
that the user has entered.
Sorry, the registration
ID that the user
has gotten back from GCM.
And then I'm posting
that up to my server.
So my server will get
that registration ID,
so that whenever I want
to try and send messages
to any of my clients, it
has that registration ID
and it will send it down to the
client that I'm executing here.
Clear.
OK.
So if I'm going too fast or if
there's any thing confusing,
just feel free to interrupt.
We're all very informal here.
Just yell out if
you've any questions.
And that's pretty much it for
registering my application
with Google Cloud
Messaging in order
for my server to be able to
send messages via Google Cloud
Messaging to my application.
And then a quick
look at the listener.
Let's see.
Earlier I mentioned, and
I showed in the slide,
it's just something that
extends GcmListenerService.
And then I override
the on message
receives method in that.
And there I'm getting my from
and getting my bundle of data.
I'm taking a message out
of that, as a string,
and I'm sending a notification.
And then this code here,
if you've ever built
a notification in Android
will look very familiar.
I'm just using a
notification compat.builder.
This send notification has
nothing to do with Google Cloud
Messaging.
This is just taking
that string that
was received from the Google
Cloud Messaging server
and turning it into
a notification.
It's straightforward.
It's pretty standard code.
All right.
So when I run this, I will get
something that looks like this.
All right.
So it's the two text
fields that I mentioned
that I'm going to
enter, you know,
I can put whatever
I want in there.
And it was a name and an email.
So I'm just saying my
name is phone demo name.
The email was hello@room and
there was a register button.
Now I had done this
earlier, so I will show you
what the server looks like.
So who's familiar with
PHP here, first of all.
OK.
And then you've probably heard
of a tool called my PHP admin.
All right.
So my PHP admin
is a tool, that's
a web based tool, that allows
you to inspect and play
with MySQL backend database.
So I know the font is really
small here in my browser.
But what I had done
here was I earlier
while you guys were
in the keynote,
I ran this application
in the emulator.
on my phone.
And I hit that register button
in order to generate a token
and register it.
And as a result, I got these
two records in my database.
And you can see the GCM reg
ID is that long string, is
the actual token.
And that's the unique
identifier for the device that's
running the Cloud
Messaging-- sorry,
for the device that's running
the app that will consume
the Cloud Messaging.
But what I'm going to do now,
just to show that this is real,
is I'm going to delete them.
So I'll come in here.
And in PHP admin
I can delete them.
And that will take a moment.
All right.
So now I have
nothing registered.
And if I go back to
my site-- and I'll
talk about how to build a
site like this in a moment--
we should see after
refresher-- there
are no devices registered yet.
So now if I come
into my emulator,
and I'll just say, hello@room
again, something like that.
So we see it
something different.
I'll hit register.
It's a really poorly
designed application.
I don't have a spinning
status or anything
like that on the register.
So it will take a
moment to register.
I'll come back and
I'll refresh the site.
And we should see, in
a moment-- like I said
this is a free public site.
Hopefully, my Wi-Fi is working.
And he hasn't registered.
I'll try and rerun
it again in a moment.
Just let that refresh.
Everybody hitting
Wi-Fi at the same time.
So it's still waiting.
Nope.
OK.
Isn't it always
like that when you
try to run a demo live
on stage it never works.
You run it before hand
while-- I ran it before hand
while you guys were in the
keynote and it worked great
and I run it now
and it's like, no.
It's another try.
Call it that.
phone@home.com, something
like that, let me register.
And refresh.
Pray to the demo gods.
Pray to the Wi-Fi gods
and nothing's happening.
I'll come back to
that in a moment.
All right.
So we can talk a little
bit about the App Server
and then I'll see if the
demo is behaving after that.
So earlier we saw this was how
I built the Android App, which
isn't working right now.
But the Android app was
just very straightforward.
It was a single activity.
There were a couple
of text fields.
There was a register
button on that.
When I registered I
called GCMs black box
in order to get that
registration token back.
I had a couple of them
from that, which I
deleted before the demo failed.
And those registration
tokens would then
be captured by my backend server
and stored by my backend server
and then used by
my backend server
if I want to talk to
individual devices,
or I could take all
of them if I want
to talk to all of my devices.
So how do we build
an App Server?
What does this thing look like?
Well, first of all,
there's a database in it.
And I gave a sneak peek
of that a moment ago
when I was using my PHP admin.
So in this case,
very simple MySQL
backend database and storing
the registration tokens.
And it's storing just the
name and ID that I had.
I have a UI for
sending messages.
You saw that, basic UI.
It's just a simple HTML UI.
And then there's the interface
to Google Cloud Messaging
itself that requests the
messages to be routed
either to one device
or multiple devices
based on those registration
ID's that had come out
of the devices.
And this is pretty much
what it would look like.
In this application
that I was showing
a moment ago would
look like this.
So my Android would
call register.php,
pass the three things, the
name, the email address,
and the registration token and
register.php would then just
store them in the database.
Then the user
interface for this,
what I was using in my browser,
I'm just calling index of PHP.
And what index PHP was doing
was do a query of everybody
in the database, get
their registration tokens,
and just generate that
UI that would allow
me to send to individual
ones or allow me to send them
all in one shot.
And then ultimately--
and then, the main part
was the gcmsend.php.
And this file, what
it does is just
using cURL to talk to the
Google Cloud Messaging backend,
picking the IDs that it wants
to-- based on the tokens
that it wants to
send the messages to,
sticking them into
headers, taking
the string of the
message, passing that
to Google Cloud Messaging,
and then fire and forget.
It's done.
At that point, the messages
would be routed back
to my various devices.
So here's a quick
example of this
is what the registration
would look like.
So if you've ever seen
PHP, this is PHP 001.
I'm taking a look at
the post for the name,
the post of the email
and I'm taking a look at the
post for the register ID.
I'm taking them and I'm
using a just MySQL query
to store them in the database.
I have a couple of things
here, the DB functions,
which is just a class that
wraps the mySQL-- what
do they call them?
MySQL admin stuff.
So that I can actually
just call DB store user
and pass those parameters to
it and then an insert query
will be generated for
me that will push them
into the database.
Sending messages with cURL
This is how easy it is.
First of all the URL is
android.googleapis.com/gcm/send.
On that, I pass a
couple of headers.
The first of these
is my API key.
If you remember way back in
the beginning, I was saying,
you use the Google Developers
Console with the Wizard
that was at that URL
and that will give you
the Sender ID and your API Key.
This is your API Key, you put
it in the authorization header.
And the content type then
I'm going to post to this
is JSON, that also
goes in the header.
And then, finally, the,
how I send the data to it.
I have a string
that I call data,
which you can see here,
towards the bottom.
So I have a data field.
And I put that string into that.
And then I have an array
of registration IDs.
So if I'm picking one
registration ID, one based
on its tokens to send to
just a target one device,
I'd put one in there.
If I want to send
it to everybody,
I just send it to
everybody in there.
And then I just cURL it out.
So there's a set the
headers, set the URL,
tell it that I'm posting
it, encoding in JSON.
And then call cURL exec, to
actually just do the cURL
and send the message.
So very, very straightforward,
very much 101 type PHP.
And it's just about getting
those registration IDs.
And if you know what
those registration IDs are
that you want to send to, and
GCM provides them for you,
you stick them into the
array, you encode it in JSON
and then you cURL exec back.
All right.
Let's look at the code
for the App Server.
And then I'll come back and
try and get the demo to work.
Oops.
My power saver kicked in.
Anybody familiar with coda?
Anybody use coda?
It's a great editor.
I love it.
So I'm just showing
the code here in coda.
Let me see if I can make
the font a little bigger.
Let's do-- Does
that look clearer?
All right.
Cool.
So again, the files that
I have in this, if I just
take a look at a few of them.
So first of all,
for registering-- I
got caught in my scroll
bar a little bit.
Let me see if I can get
rid of that corruption.
Weird.
OK.
So again, for
registering PHP 101.
I'm taking a look at the
post and pulling in the data
from the post.
And then I'm storing the
user in the database,
using these database
functions that I created.
And we can see what
they look like.
You know, to store a
user-- I'm sure you're all
familiar with an insert query.
OK.
I'm not doing any kind
of sensible programming
here by doing a
parameter validation
or anything like that.
I'm sure you could issue
a denial of service attack
on this because I'm not
filtering my parameters.
But, you know, you'll forgive
me for that, hopefully,
because this is a rough demo.
But again, it's just
it's MySQL query
I'm inserting into
this GCM users
table, the name, the
email, and the registration
ID for that user.
And then if I ever
want to get them back
it's just the same kind of thing
in MySQL query to get them out.
The user interface for the
app itself is indexed.php.
And if I come down to the
index.php for a second--
and you'll just see I'm
querying the database.
See I'm just
queueing my database.
I have a db.getallusers.
And then I'm going to loop
through and just generate
HTML forms, one for each user.
And then one for
all of these users.
And then those HTML forms.
As we can see
here, they're going
to-- when I submit
them, they're just
going to call the send PHP, that
I spoke about earlier on where
I put the message
into it and I put
the list of all the
registration IDs
that I want to have
in there in it.
And if I go back to my
browser for a second
what that looks
like was this one.
So let's see if that
user got registered yet.
no.
Oh, there it is.
OK.
So if finally came out.
So when I was running
on my emulator,
you see now this box that
appeared was for that user.
I'll rerun it on my
phone in a moment
so we can see what
it would look like.
But now I have one
user in the database.
So I have one GCM
token in the database,
which is for this user.
And if I type a message in
here say like, hello room
and send it.
Hopefully, it'll show
up in the emulator.
There it goes.
And you see the notification
just appeared in the emulator.
And when I drag
it down we can see
that GCM message, hello room.
So if anybody wants to send a
message to me, keep it clean.
You can actually
see the URL there.
This is running live-- this
app server's running live
on the internet.
And like right now I
also have here, just say,
please keep it
clean on this one.
And this is just to send
to all registered devices.
And I don't know if you
can actually hear it.
And there is the message
actually appearing.
And you can see how quick that
was, as soon as I had typed it.
And that's going to my emulator.
So the emulator is receiving
that message from GCM
and actually
rendering it in there.
OK.
So any questions
on the PHP part?
Is it clear?
Clear as mud?
So that's what a
very, very simple app
server would look like.
This really-- there's several
things that it needs to do.
First of all, you need to--
and just, I heard the sounds.
Did somebody just
send something?
I just heard the sound
of a notification.
Yep.
We got a smiley face up there.
So there's several things
that it needs to do.
So first of all, when your
Android application has-- I
need to turn off my sound.
Messages are all popping in now.
So when your Android application
registers with Google Cloud
Messaging, you will get a token.
You need to-- Google
Cloud Messaging doesn't
have any intelligence about
sending the messages for you.
It's just the black box.
You call that black box and
tell it to send messages
to devices on your behalf.
That token is the
identifier for it.
So in your App Server, you
need to store that token.
Now there's a million different
ways you could have done it.
I just decided to use this free
public PHP server to do it,
stored the token in
a MySQL database.
You could add a lot more
intelligence to that.
You could have, for example,
people from Singapore
have a column in the
database to identify
they're from Singapore,
and people from London.
If you came in
late, I was talking
about an example of
an application that
ran in Singapore and New
York and London, that's
why I'm picking those two.
And it's obviously it's up to
you how you would build it.
It's up to you how
you would design it.
It's up to you how you would
filter out your messages.
And how you would
have users work
in peer groups or whatever.
But don't forget,
there's also the concept
of topics in Google
Cloud Messaging, which
I'll talk about in a moment.
But that's the most
important thing,
is that your
application server needs
to be able to send
the messages--
or needs to be able to tell
Google Cloud Messaging to send
the messages.
And as a result, you need
to track the user's tokens.
So my demonstration
there was just
to take them and stick
them into a MySQL PHP.
And then your application
server, the other thing
that it has to do, is then just
simply call the Google Cloud
Messaging APIs.
Pass it, if you're using
the HTTP post methodology,
you pass it a JSON
encoded string that
has a list of the
registration IDs
plus the message
that you want to send
and then it handles the rest.
And it does it pretty
quickly as you saw.
Is it safe to look at the other
messages you guys have sent?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: How
does this work in iOS?
Well, that's a great idea.
We should actually have this
as a way for doing questions.
It does work on iOS.
We don't have Google
Play Services,
but there are a set of
GCM libraries for iOS.
I don't know that much
about them to be honest.
But GCM works across-- we
have a web client for it.
So you can actually
send messages
to HTML, JavaScript, base sites.
There is an iOS client for it.
There are a number of libraries
that you can use in iOS.
They're not in
Google Play Services.
And then, of course, on Android
there's Google Play Service.
Another question over here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: My understanding
is that in order
to be able to receive
properly, your phone
has to send [INAUDIBLE] in order
for the message to be sent.
So when you register for
it, is this something
that's always on when
you have the Google Play
Services on your phone?
Is it just on by default?
[INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's a
lot of good questions there.
So first of all,
it's not always on.
It's on when your
application is running,
if your application is
built for using GCM.
That wake lock permission
that I spoke about earlier on,
is the key to it.
So the idea behind that
is that like that's
what you're giving
your app permission to
wake the phone upon
an incoming message.
I don't know the specifics about
how much battery it's using.
But one of the things
is that we've actually
built this to
optimize for battery
use in these connected
messaging scenarios.
So you're always
listening for messages,
but it's extremely
low battery usage.
I don't have the stats
on how much it is,
but that's one of the core
tenets of how we've actually
built it was to keep the battery
usage as low as possible.
Just to repeat the question--
sorry for the folks who
didn't hear it-- it
was if Google Cloud
Messaging, if an
app builds using it
is always connected in
order to listen to messages,
what's the impact going
to be on the battery?
And is there any
way to turn it off?
Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So you can build
your app to sniff
for when a connection
fails and then you
would generate a notification
to your user if that happens.
So yes.
And if you are
actually disconnected
for a period of time, like
you go off the grid, when
you come back on the grid GCM
actually has your messages
for you and will
resend them to you.
The messages don't get lost.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Something like that.
Yeah.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So just moving on.
So step four is just
enjoy the awesomeness,
as I like to call it.
So as you saw there I
run it in the emulator.
I can also run it on my phone.
It's registering and sending
messages to any or all devices.
It's totally free of charge.
We don't charge anything.
And answering a
question for you,
there is a guaranteed
message delivery.
So that if you do
get disconnected,
the messages will actually
be resent for you.
Next steps, Upstream
messages are also possible.
So in this case, I
had a server that I
had built that was sending
a message down to my device,
but I could also send from
my device up to the server
and have that route my
message to other devices.
So I could have like
that type of-- I
can either have Upstream
messages for something
like a bulletin board,
or Upstream messages
to have them routed.
So I can do a Peer
to Peer type thing.
This topic, so that
you don't get flooded
with too many messages, you
can actually subscribe or send
to particular topics.
So again, using my
scenario of the bank
that I was talking about
with Singapore, London,
and New York branches, the
buy side and the sell side,
in each of these,
could have a topic.
And as a result, not
everybody reads every message.
If I'm only interested in
the buy side in Singapore,
then I could just
receive messages
for the buy side in
Singapore, that type of thing.
Priorities, there are
messages priorities too,
so that you can set
different levels of priority
of a message.
That's something that's
actually evolving in Google Play
Services so watch out for--
we have some new stuff coming
into Google Play
Services very, very soon
and there's some changes
in priorities there.
But just in managing
priorities, so
you can have like high
level messages and low level
messages so that if you have
built an application that,
for example, receives
messages as notifications,
like the one that I build
here, so that you don't get,
keep getting pinged
by notifications,
you can change
priority of messages,
maybe some generate
a notification,
maybe some get routed to an
intent for later viewing.
To learn more, we have
this side developers.googl
e.com/cloudmessaging/gcm.
There's also this
new thing, I think
it has been released by now.
If not, it's
releasing imminently
called the gcm-playground.
The guys told me I could
talk about it today.
So it's all right.
If you go to
github.com/googlesamples/gcm
playground, and they have a
similar type of application
to what I've built here, except
they've built it in Goal,
because they thought Goal
was much nicer than PHP.
No flame wars, please.
And there's also some
great DevBytes out there.
So DevBytes, if you're familiar
with Google Developers,
these short videos
that we produce,
three to five minutes long,
just talking about technology.
And there's one great one
here from my colleague, Jarek.
I don't know why they put
the about the speaker's slide
at the end of the deck.
I don't know.
That was a template.
So about the speaker,
that I mentioned
I'm a Developer and
Advocate at Google.
I've authored like about
20 programming books.
And I've changed into
writing children's novels.
Now this is my latest one.
It's the cover reveal
was just yesterday.
So I was so happy that I was
able to put it into my slides.
And it's coming out next month.
And I'm the host at
Google, a show called
"Coffee with a Googler."
Anybody watch it?
Yeah.
Thank you.
You know, and by the way,
if you've any requests
for people for me to talk to
at "Coffee with a Googler,"
please let me know.
And contact details, so
on Twitter I'm @lmoroney.
On +, I'm +laurencemoroney.
And facebook.com
laurence.moroney.
And if you want
to email me, it's
the same, lmoroney@google.com.
So we have a few minutes if
anybody has any questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Around what, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Token invalidation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
AUDIENCE: Do we need to
register any receivers
or check to see if
the GCM code that we
have has been validated?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So the
question for everybody else
was that, in the past,
there have been issues
around token invalidations.
Do we need to double
check our tokens to see?
I'm not familiar with
any token invalidation
problems, first of all.
But I would argue that
it's always a good idea
to double check.
And so we have this
new instance ID
API, which is part of
Google Cloud Messaging.
And I believe you can use
that to check your token.
So maybe every few
days or something
of running an
application-- excuse me--
that you could just do a
recheck and validate your token.
It would be a good idea.
So over here again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Is there
a round trip facility
where a server can receive--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm sorry.
It's hard to--
AUDIENCE: I seem
to remember there
was a round trip
method where you
can send a response [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Good question.
I've never tried it.
So I don't know.
I'm only going to guess.
My reckon-- my
guess would be no.
That it would be
better to send them up
through the regular
channel so that way
you get the guaranteed delivery.
If you have that
open connection,
I have no idea what's
on the other end
and how it would respond to it.
I would always just recommend
go through door number one.
But I don't know for sure.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So the question is when
I got the registration
token for a device,
is it device specific?
I've a funny story
about that question.
Because I knew somebody
was going to ask it today.
So I decided to go
and look up the code
that I had used in my demo
to just check that for sure.
And it turned out I was
using deprecated code.
And that was like 20
minutes before my talk.
And so we made a
note up stairs that
was saying, before
you do a talk,
make sure you don't
do a deprecated code.
So anyway.
But to answer your question,
if you're using the instance ID
APIs, you can have a
single registration token
across multiple devices
so that if you receive
a notification on
one of your devices,
you want to receive
it on all of them,
rather than it being routed
to multiple ones that has them
being identified differently.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: It can be.
So you can have it so that
you have a registration
token that's unique pair device,
or you can have a registration
token that's shared across
ones based on your Google ID.
In the back here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
communications protocol
does GCM use?
So when you're coming Downstream
from GCM to the server,
I actually don't know.
I've never looked at it.
If I'm going Upstream
from my App Server to GCM,
it's just an HDTP post.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So if you've built
an application for
Android TV, how do you
receive the notification?
I believe it's just the same.
You extend the same class.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
service is not available?
Can I get your details and
I'll check in on that when
I've-- I've never tried it.
So I don't really know.
Time for maybe two
more questions.
The front here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: What
are the what, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Payload size.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Payload
size for messages, oh boy.
Yeah.
It's on the sites.
What was it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: 256 kilobytes.
OK.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, thank you everybody.
And enjoy the rest
of your Android BBQ.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]